hey I'm Chad knee this is hashtag news
what's trending on Twitter well kids are
sarcastically tweeting thanks Michelle
Obama with pictures of the disgusting
school lunches I don't know what these
kids are complaining about because I
think these lunches are actually nice oh
you okay uh-huh
obviously today's biggest story is the
national holiday of black Friday's Eve
I'm gonna do my best to catch you up on
this year's Thanksgiving in under a
minute all right editor can I get 60
seconds somewhere on this screen
here we go in the same story as every
year Black Friday starting even earlier
and the gold medal for crapping in your
cranberry sauce goes to Kmart they're
opening at six a [__]
on Thanksgiving Day who's asking you to
open that early hey Mark I'm pretty sure
what you think is a line of people
begging you to open before anyone else
is actually the group of homeless people
who hang outside of Kmart all this
because people just want some deals on
some stuff it's like people completely
abandon the meaning of the holiday for a
bunch of cheap boom boxes VCRs
look I see you're confused I don't think
you truly understand Black Friday so let
me explain through song
seven a.m minutes Thanksgiving gotta cut
it short gotta go shopping relatives are
here from out of town but big price drop
won't keep me around lines are long so
long everybody's rushing so glad that I
paid this kid who's been waiting for me
since Tuesday for Black Friday Friday
gotta get there on Thursday be a good
American and desert your family if you
want to hear the full version of that
song go ahead and click nowhere because
I have self-respect did I do it we
wanted more song yeah really
now for the challenge portion as
suggested by Nathan Jordan I'm gonna
deliver the news while trying to order a
pizza over the phone this is gonna suck
thanks buddy but let's give it a go oh
buddy butt
okay today and tomorrow are great times
to gather together as a family watch the
trailers for the new Jurassic Park and
Star Wars the latest and two massive
film franchises what's even crazier is
that both trailers end up with Will
Smith showing up at the end to try to
get everyone to forget about the
franchise's previous sequels
oh you there
oh I'm sorry yeah no I'm sorry I just
I'm just caught up in a lot of things at
the moment yeah so you know I was trying
to order a large pizza pepperoni uh
yeah it's for delivery polish officials
shot down a proposal that would make
beloved bear Winnie the Pooh the mascot
for their latest City Park not only
because the bear doesn't want pants but
also because the exposed region doesn't
clearly indicate the Bear's gender which
first of all Poland do you want that
region to more clearly illustrate whose
gender but second who cares all my
favorite fictional characters have
ambiguous genitals Pikachu Ninja Turtles
Squidward any cartoon duck Lord Varys
uh yeah anyway so the pizza yeah I'm
still here I'm still here
okay it's uh
uh how long did you say it was gonna
take
all right and something we're all
thankful for Beyonce released a new
music video for her latest single
7-Eleven features exactly zero Slurpees
hot dogs or turkey jerky but instead
it's just a simple video of Beyonce
dancing in her underwear while she
literally describes the dances that she
moves along doing
my hands up the song it's super catchy
but I haven't even seen the actual video
I'm pretty sure I can figure out the
dance moves though based on the lyrics
so here's my take
hit it
down yeah
anyways sorry about that uh just real
real busy doing some things here
yeah I'm at work so it's like I'm kind
of multitasking here
cash
thank you so much ma'am bye-bye love you
he was like really patient
okay that was fun so this year like
every year the president's gonna have to
Pardon a turkey and we ask you guys
what's the worst crime a turkey could
have committed using
crimes at canardo says turkey
responsible for after dinner
kidnapping oh I see what you did there
with the space bar nice touch we got
Cena La committing poultryes in oh can I
see what I see that yep Indy Trent
flaunting exposed breasts oh underline
the rest I liked it I liked it okay so
uh that's it for this week make sure
what's up
16 okay uh this one you can keep change
uh all right so that's it for this week
uh like this video if you like your
cartoon smooth down there whatever that
means subscribe to see more of my texts
from my mom last night don't forget to
suggest a challenge for next week's
sucker to suffer through I'm Chad need
and this is hashtag news
meetings are later
yeah
it's a new show hashtag news all right
yeah you have not heard of it I
guarantee it